tras la reelección del presidente
no hubo duda sobre el nombramiento de su
nuevo Primer Ministro
lichian de 63 años recibió casi todos
los votos de los delegados al congreso
nacional popular
prometo ser Leal a la Constitución de la
República popular china salvaguardar La
autoridad de la Constitución cumplir mis
obligaciones legales ser Leal al país y
al pueblo yo lichan presto este
juramento
y es el ex jefe del partido comunista de
Shanghai la ciudad más grande de China y
su reputación se resintió al supervisar
el angustioso cierre total por covid del
año pasado pero es uno de los aliados de
mayor confianza del presidente
se le considera Alguien que ha llegado a
la cima porque tiene esta relación muy
fuerte con Así que no hay dudas al
respecto es alguien que es considerado
como amigable con los negocios
su nombramiento forma parte de una
iniciativa general de shide nombrar a un
grupo de leales en puestos clave para
consolidar aún más su poder tras ser
reafirmado como jefe del partido
comunista en octubre el Primer Ministro
saliente
se ha visto cada vez más marginado a
medida que shir reforzaba su control
sobre la toma de decisiones su sucesor
cuya función será gestionar la economía
china se enfrenta ahora a la tarea de
dirigir la recuperación del país tras el
cierre y en medio de las crecientes
tensiones comerciales y tecnológicas con
occidente